but first of all alireza is with
christian
alireza first of all congratulations
what a titanic struggle you tried to get
the hat trick but in the end in that
armageddon it didn't happen at the same
time even after
that loss you are still smiling take us
through your feelings right now
yeah
it's uh i had hat rick i won gct sing
phil and sing louise so that's a hat
trick yeah this was
quadruple
but yeah no fabian played very well
today so
um he beat wesley and yeah then
i think he deserves to win the
tournament
how did you feel uh today's rounds take
us through the first three rounds i
played well i missed a lot of chances i
think against hikaru i should just play
for win and
forget about drauga i think i was much
better but the first round i am most
mad about because against peter it was
just completely winning i think just f3
was winning and then instead of fg
so
it wasn't yeah f3 so yeah
i i completely okay i was very tired
today also so i'm happy that i managed
to
go to the turbine contest but still in
the tie breaks you actually won on
demand with the black pieces and you
started off with that enterprising h6
how did you come up to
that conclusion yeah it's a i understood
immediately that it's kind of corrode
composition to get the bishop on h7 and
push d5 looked very interesting
probably it's not the best way but it
looked very interesting and i played
very well that game so
but yeah norman
this was just a mess so i cannot be sad
about it still a very successful trip to
saint louis
sum it up for us
yeah it was a great
events here everything was very
high-level
um really saint joyce is a great city i
think when i when we came here with
family we were very comfortable
from the beginning and
it kind of felt like home even so
the hotel was good they can't plane
condition was great so it's one of my
favorite places now
and it's
and my chest was i think very good
um i think
i lost only two games in the
whole three events so that was a good
performance but in general
um yeah i'm very happy i hope to be back
here
and
yeah
it could have been it could have
couldn't have been better
alireza big congratulations for you we
definitely hope to see you soon here in
st louis congratulations thanks and our
congratulations as well indeed uh ali
raised a wonderful wonderful performance
he will return to france
a very very happy man i mean he has done
something
quite shocking and unprecedented